we have a voicemail number it's 2192
david p take a listen to this voicemail
that came in so you're worried that
lying to the FBI is a felony well lying
under oath to Congress is also a felony
that's what he already did you didn't
seem to have any concerns with that
you're okay we're back yeah Pat how long
is but but but Hillary's emails going to
be a defense during the trump
administration we're a month in okay
we're three months out from the election
we're a month into the trump presidency
for how long are people going to be
saying but Hillary's emails probably for
four years probably the entire trump
presidency because during Obama's
administration we would point out the
horrible things that george w bush did
and they kind of pass that off to like
Obama's the president now move on with
it yeah Todd survey calm / Pakman please
help us out this will take you under a
minute to fill out and it will be really
useful to us in talking to potential
david pakman show advertisers pod survey
com / PA que ma n check it out and
participate it really won't take long on
the bonus show today what's the bonus
show you might be asking great question
every day we do the regular show it's an
hour but then we do another show it's
called the bonus show and it's for our
paid subscribers that support the
production of the show at david
pakman.com slash membership we have a
coupon code if you want to sign up it's
i voted 17 by all means have at it on
the bonus show today uber has hired eric
holder to investigate claims of sexual
harassment i have some stories from
friends about uber driver sexual
harassment which i will tell on today's
show does pat have stories of sexual
harassment involving rubra we will find
out don't tell us that we will find out
on the bonus show our DC trump
supporters favoring a drink called
fireball it is a vile and disgusting
drink which apparently shares an
ingredient or two with antifreeze we'll
talk to Pat about whether he's tried
fireball on today's bonus show don't
answer that question either
that and also NPR has created a team
devoted to covering president Trump's
conflicts of interest this makes a lot
of sense because the conflicts of
interest are so significant that you
probably need a team to cover Trump's
conflicts of interest we will be talking
about all of those stories and more on
the bonus show if that sounds good sign
up for membership at david pakman.com
slash membership that is the number one
funding source for the show and it comes
with great member benefits including
access to the bonus show and lots of
other cool stuff you can get a major
discount off of membership by using the
coupon code I voted 17 when you sign up
i will also just tell everybody who has
taken the general david pakman survey at
david pakman.com slash survey we are
tabulating all of the results Pat has
brought in a series of protractors and
texas instruments graphing calculators
and stuff to get all the results tallied
and we are going to have the interesting
feedback we received from the audience
on the show for you very very soon so
thanks to everybody who took that survey
pod survey calm / Pakman for the new
survey this is now a survey show we
basically just do surveys and report on
surveys I'm kidding after the survey
we're done with surveys please take it
talk to you on the bonus show